all right here's the deal we're doing a
prank just left Co and you guys so it is
the trade deadline we're recording this
on Tuesday and we thought we'd fire up
Photoshop and convince Sims that Odell
is being traded to the Texans I think
it's gonna work even better we're in
full costume because it's Halloween
look at this dangerous how do you feel
as a brunette negative ghostrider the
pattern is full oh my god
oh my god I think you're lying no oh my
god right
Oh BJ was traded to the Texans hold my
god are you guys seeing this yeah bro
bro yo bro Football Talk oh poor game
games and have a heart attack dude my
Super Bowl pic the Texans I I love that
we set it on the pot yesterday hold on
them our family what did he get what do
they get for him a first and a second
and Houston will also get a sick only a
first at a second all right that's
pretty good no they had to take the
salary into account man dude damn they
might be my new favorite team Wow
do we change the whole show gosh damn
what did we talk about in the opening
I don't know Hugh yeah you know what's
crazy as your first guess was right
Houston no my first guess was like yeah
this a real bro you just got pranked on
Halloween
are you kidding me you yes Gabe did you
know this game everybody knew Chris
everybody knew guys everybody knew how
did you do this like a huge pro football
talk to make it real to see I know let
go though you see that he doesn't do
this I know his tails like I have a full
house still buffered though still fell
for him I really didn't gosh
I'm gonna I'm gonna put all of you in
headlocks and one by one